good afternoon everybody and
to the Macmillan center I me and Shapiro
her currently I have responsibility for
directing the Macmillan Center and one
of the most interesting and fun aspects
of that job is to invite and introduce
the coca-cola world fun lecturer we're
delighted to host eboo patel as the
speaker with this year's actually I was
just noticing the Dakota Commonwealth
Fund electric eel was created in 1992 so
with the booze presentation it actually
comes of age this is the 21st year of
the of the coca-cola lecture was
established by the late Robert Roboto
you tiara who was at that time the chair
and CEO of the coca-cola foundation and
he was an alumnus of yale college class
of nineteen fifty-three his ambition was
to support the intersecting endeavors
among specialist in international
relations international law
international enterprises and
organizations the Macmillan center
sponsors this event along with the law
school in the School of Management eboo
Patel is the founder and president of
the interfaith youth core in Chicago
growing out of the community will out of
community organizing ebru did there the
interfaith youth core capitalizes on the
positive force of faith to bring young
people of diverse backgrounds together
and in our communities it was named by
US News and World Report is one of he
was named by US News and World Report is
one of America's best leaders of 2009
and he was the one of books sacred
ground blur ilysm prejudice and the
promise of America and is 2007 order
the acts of faith the story of an
American Muslim and the struggle for the
soul from a generation which one the
Louisville gram n O Lord religion he's
also a regular contributor as I'm sure
many of you know to the Washington Post
USA Today Huffington Post NPR and CNN
ebu is a also a member of President
Obama's advisory another community
organizer from Chicago President Obama
advisory council approval of the white
of the White House Office to faith-based
and neighborhood partnerships is lecture
to gable will run for around 40 to 45
minutes which will then give us time for
some discussion questions and answers
and will will a to wind up by about 5 30
after which everybody will be invited to
join us for a reception outside it's a
great pleasure for me to be able to
invite you to welcome you here today the
title that evil his chosen voice
lecturers religious conflicts religious
cooperation toward a field of intimate
interfaith studies and pleased
introducing
so I take special joy and speaking of
campuses that I was not smart enough to
get into as an undergrad of which Yale
is probably top of that list so thank
you all for coming this afternoon thank
you to Professor Shapiro for hosting me
and inviting me and one of the best
things about doing about giving the
title for a talk several months in
advance is that you actually have to
write that talk and fill out what you
mean by toward a feel of field of
interfaith studies so here is my
meditation and that at least over the
past couple of months I want to start
with somebody who did a talk at Yale
some years back in two thousand four
former Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright came to Yale Divinity School to
deliver a talk called the mighty and the
Almighty on the subject of religion and
foreign policy in that talk and in the
book of the same title that followed
secretary Albright spoke of the profound
shift in her understanding of foreign
policy from an endeavor where religion
was seen as summer between peripheral
and irrelevant to one in which
understanding the energies around
religion was viewed as essential she had
come of age in an era that celebrated
modernity a time in which the best
sociologists assumed that the process of
modernization was inherently linked to
secularization she speaks of it as a
historical moment where foreign policy
specialists studied George Kennan and
Dean Acheson paid close attention to the
political tides of nationalism and
socialism and rarely mentioned God in
public or viewed religion as a force to
be reckoned with it all when Harvard
political scientist Samuel Huntington
wrote The Clash of Civilizations in the
mid-1990s Albright says we did all we
could to distance ourselves from that
theory we had in mind a future in which
nations and regions drew closer as
democratic bonds grew stronger not a
world splitting apart along historic
fault lines of culture and Creed even
the foreign policy issues secretary
Albright dealt with directly in the
Clinton administration the Balkans warm
the Middle East peace process she and
her colleagues viewed in secular terms
the rights of individuals the dividing
lines of land 911 shifted the paradigm
showing that the path ahead would mix
religion and foreign policy in profound
ways but it also cast a light backwards
illuminating how the Foreign Affairs
issues of the 1990s from the Balkans in
the Middle East to Northern Ireland in
South Asia were shot up with religious
energies in her book secretary Albright
recalls many situations from her foreign
policy career that in retrospect had
profound religious dimensions she talks
of how the visit of Pope John Paul the
second to Poland energized the
anti-communist movement there and how
the return of the Ayatollah to Iran in
1979 took the entire American foreign
policy establishment by surprise she
writes about the emergence of
faith-based extremist movements like
Joseph Kony's Lord's Resistance Army and
Osama bin Laden's al Qaeda the religious
issues that complicated the Middle East
negotiations in the faith filled
conflicts raging across the world it
turns out that those 1960s era
sociologists were wrong the world is not
necessarily headed down a path of
disbelief one particularly prominent
secularization theorists Peter Berger
revised his view in this pithy line the
world is as furiously religious as ever
and in some cases more so than ever
arguably the issues around religion may
be more important in the next 20 years
than they were in the past 20 there is a
great deal of attention paid to whether
nations undergoing transitions to
democracy Tunisia Egypt Iraq Libya soon
Syria perhaps Bahrain can build stable
representative governments and economies
that employ a reasonable percentage of
their populations but even a quick
glance at the New York Times on any
given day reveals that an equally
important question is how groups who
orient around religion differently
within those nations are going to relate
to one another Sunni Shia and Kurds in
Iraq sufis and sulla fees and Tunisia
kwani secular Muslims and Christians in
Egypt and this is a dynamic that's true
beyond the Middle East who knew there
was a group called rahunga Muslims in
Myanmar and that the dat nation
storybook Democratic
opening last year would be marred by
violence between its Buddhists and its
Muslims nations undergoing a transition
to democracy are likely the most
vulnerable to this type of
inter-religious civil conflict precisely
because the sectarian oriented
authoritarian governments that ruled
before gave favored to some groups think
Sunni Baathists in Iraq or Allah whites
in Syria fomenting reprisals when those
dictatorships are overthrown but this is
a dynamic that's relevant to other parts
of the world also tension still
simmering between the Catholics and
Protestants of Northern Ireland as well
as the Serbian Orthodox Christians and
the Bosnian Muslims of the Balkans
Christian Muslim conflict within Nigeria
as a significant problem and sectarian
violence between Sunnis and Shias and
Pakistan has resulted in the outright
murder of hundreds of mostly Shia
Muslims last year alone and the growing
Muslim populations of Europe are
increasingly being met with restrictions
on their religious liberties the banning
of head scarves the limiting of mosques
and vicious nativist movements
furthermore this is not simply an over
their problem the United States is the
most religiously diverse nation in human
history and the most religiously devout
nation in the West at this moment of
global religious conflict mitt romney's
run for president revealed ugly
anti-mormon strains among some segments
of the American population in the past
several years dozens of mosques have
been have encountered opposition by City
Council's and citizens groups some of it
violent as an arson fifty percent of
americans report that they would not
vote for an atheist or humanist for
president and more than a few atheists
in recent years have made their name and
sold a lot of books by taking an
aggressively hostile stance against all
forms of religion moreover we have
diaspora groups from each of the
communities fighting elsewhere right
here in America often living
cheek-by-jowl these groups feel deeply
connected to the fate of their
co-religionists elsewhere simply put
when violence occurs between Israelis
and Palestinians in the Middle East
tension rises between
muslim groups in the midwest the term
diversity and professional and
educational circles in the united states
is frequently used as positive on its
face needing no justification diversity
is our strength diversity in riches us
these are common statements you probably
heard them in freshman orientation those
of you who are students here but harvard
professor of comparative religions Diana
Eck points out that diversity is simply
a demographic fact the situation in
which people with different identities
live in close quarters the term says
nothing about how those people get along
with one another frankly if all we knew
about religious diversity was the
stories carried on the international
news it would be hard to conclude
anything but that religious diversity in
many parts of the world at least is a
recipe for conflict recent social
science provides a window into the
complexities around diversity Robert
Putnam in his skype lecture found that
the most common result of diversity
would dennis city is that it causes
people to quote unquote hunker down
isolating themselves in eroding the
social capital of the broader community
this creates a vacuum for groups
invested in spreading prejudice or
building barriers to sow the seeds of
division and conflict and religious
conflict can be especially deadly it's
kind of not only do the participants
believe they are fighting for cosmic
reasons where death may be welcomed as
martyrdom but religious communities are
the largest repositories of social
capital in many civil societies
providing endless amounts of energy
people and resources to mobilize what if
that social capital between religious
communities could be bridged and people
who orient around religion differently
could be convinced to cooperate with one
another what if the cosmic narratives of
religious traditions could be nudged to
consider the religious other as a
partner in the quest for the kingdom on
earth many of the great social movements
of the 20th century hinh Swaraj and
India the civil rights movement in the
United States the struggle in south
africa
a profound interfaith character what if
the great line from the 1893 Parliament
of the world's religions in Chicago from
now on the great religions of the world
make war no longer on each other and
instead on the giant ills that afflicts
humankind what if that line can be made
a reality this is the hope of the
interfaith movement there has been a
dramatic growth in interfaith activity
over the past 20 years linked to the
increasing diversity that many people
are now experiencing and also to the
prevalence of high-profile religious
extremism and conflict a half century
ago few cities had any organized
interfaith programs today dozens have
some sort of initiative everything from
Interfaith councils to festivals of
faith religious denominations have
invited leaders from other religions to
give keynotes of their gatherings local
congregations have started interfaith
exchange programs think tanks have
commissioned task forces and issued
reports the United Nations launched a
major interfaith initiative called the
alliance of civilizations Muslim and
kiss Muslim and Christian theologians
unveiled a document called a common word
between us and you celebrated world
religions author Karen Armstrong used
her TED Prize to issue a charter of
compassion calling all religions to
redefine themselves by that shared core
value Prince's prime ministers and
presidents have all in various ways lent
their support to the Interfaith cause I
remember standing in the Oval Office
with President Obama at the first
meeting of his inaugural faith council
when he spoke of the importance of
interfaith cooperation as a way to
strengthen America's Civic fabric and to
show the world that conflict between
faiths is not inevitable the Academy has
gotten into the act as well the American
Academy of religion the largest body for
religion scholars in North America
recently made interfaith studies a
permanent study group not only are there
excellent interfaith activities run by
diversity offices and chaplain seas but
universities about the conference's
started classes and supported research
on interfaith cooperation Yale
unsurprisingly is a leader in this area
with the presence of faculty and staff
like Sharon Coogler Omar bajwa who is
here with us today
Miroslav Volf skip stout Joseph Cummings
a partnership of the 20 Blair Faith
Foundation I could go on but this is
undoubtedly a center of this type of
work in America and the world so I've
been involved in interfaith work for
some 15 years when I was just starting
out in the late 1990s and happened to
mention the term interfaith to someone I
mostly got met with a blank stare when I
tell someone now I run an interfaith
organization there's a good chance that
they shoot me a knowing look followed by
statements like it's so great that you
are working to support people's
spiritual journeys or I believe in all
religions too or my fiance is Muslim and
I'm Jewish and we can't find anyone to
do our wedding we've gone from no
recognition of a term to a hundred
different definitions of what it might
mean some of them contradictory as the
activity in this area increases one
crucial role for the Academy to play is
to give some shape and focus to what is
clearly an emerging field of research
study and practice so what follows is my
attempt to do so interfaith studies in
the Academy would examine the multiple
dimensions of how individuals and groups
who orient around religion differently
interact with one another and the
implications for communities civil
society in global politics clearly it
would be an interdisciplinary field a
psychologist might research how
individuals who grow up in a religiously
homogenous environment experience and
cope with moving to religiously diverse
surroundings a political scientist could
study why some nations have been more
effective and absorbing religious
minorities than others or why politics
is dominated by religion in some states
and not in others or perhaps the
relationship between the two a historian
would draw parallels between the
relatively tolerant empires of medieval
Islam and the democratic nation states
of contemporary North America a
sociologist might look at the role
religious institutions play in
assimilating immigrants philosophers
might compare paradigms of pluralism
theologians would elucidate how to be
Christian or Muslim or Jewish amongst
quote
old others professors of art and
literature could choose to examine any
of a thousand great works that have been
created at the crossroads of religious
imaginations without a doubt research
projects like these exist in the Academy
but they are disconnected published in
separate journals and discussed
independent of one another at different
conferences and in different departments
academic fields are useful because they
are formal spaces for a group of
colleagues to engage in long-term data
gathering sustained reflection and
extended discussion it's a question not
only of collecting things but connecting
them in cooperating together to decide
what they might mean consider similar
areas that have become fields gathering
scholars from different disciplines to
inquire connect and apply urban studies
human and family studies education
community development social work one
thing that unites these fields is a
strong practitioner dimension scholars
in these areas ask and pursue critical
research questions but they also create
programs of study that shape leaders who
do in their areas Social Work Department
sejuk eight social workers education
departments train teachers Urban Studies
department strain city managers and so
on a major part of what interfaith
studies would be about is nurturing a
cadre of professionals a group that I'm
calling interfaith leaders I'm defining
an interfaith leader as someone with the
framework knowledge base and skill set
to help individuals and communities who
orient around religion differently in
civil society and politics build mutual
respect positive relationships and a
commitment to the common good put simply
an effective interfaith leader is one
who can work with diversity to build
pluralism what I'm defining diversity
again along with Diana Eck as simply the
fact of people in groups with different
identities living in close quarters
pluralism is an achievement
characterized by three things number one
respect for different identities number
two positive relations between diverse
communities and
three a commitment to the common good
diverse societies that achieve pluralism
have a strong Civic fabric one that can
withstand the provocations of extremists
and haters and are bridging their social
capital in ways that can take on some of
the toughest social problems of that
society but bridges don't fall from the
sky or rise from the ground people build
them and the people who are on the
vanguard of such work we call leaders I
want to imagine for a moment the kind of
program that might educate and train
interfaith leaders and if you are
wondering if I was the kind of geeky
graduate student who in the middle of
writing my qualifying exams would
daydream of the type of courses i might
teach one day you are correct i was
indeed said geeky graduate student mira
can attest to that we were grad students
together I hope one day that
universities across the country offer
master's degrees in interfaith
leadership but for the purposes of this
discussion I'm imagining a concentration
in an undergraduate program a course
sequence a student might take as part of
a major and religion political science
or international relations the
foundational course would be called
religious diversity civil society and
world politics and the first text that
would be taught is Sam Huntington's
clash of civilizations the first
assignment would be to read Huntington
alongside a week's worth of the New York
Times and come to class attempting to
argue against his thesis if it is a
typically bloody week between different
religious communities there will be far
more that seems to illustrate Huntington
then seemingly disproves him this
discussion will hopefully raise a series
of questions that the rest of the course
for course rip will attempt to answer
the first question is about religious
trends Huntington was one of the first
prominent academics to say that the
secularization theory was bunk the
religious identity was deeply ingrained
in the human condition and most of
humanity was likely to identify most
closely with their faith for the
foreseeable future 20 years after the
clash of civilizations what do we know
about trends and religious
identification and that's simply about
the number of adherence of different
religions across the
but also about religious diversity
within cities nations and regions and
how people's religious orientations
shape their attitudes towards everything
from polio vaccines to separation of
quote-unquote church and state to girls
schooling the basic question is this how
devout and how diverse is our chosen
area of interest and how much is that
likely to matter for issues of peace and
stability there the second question the
Huntington conversation is likely to
raise is whether conflict between
communities who orient around religion
is indeed inevitable which Huntington
frankly suggests the third question is
related to the second if religious
violence is not inevitable in what
situations have diverse communities
coexisted and even cooperated this
question is best answered through the
literature of three disciplines one is
history simply reading about the
instances where diversity has become
coexistence or cooperation some of my
fate of my favorite works along these
lines include Yale University's Maria
Rosa meta calls the ornament of the
world about medieval Andalusia and
Zachary caravels peace be upon you a
second discipline which helps answer
this question is political theory which
raises I think the hardest and most
important questions when it comes to
religious diversity namely under what
political and social conditions can
communities who have very different
ideas of what is good and lawful on
earth based on a set of cosmic
convictions live together in the same
society professor Shapiro and I were
discussing this before coming up here
let me give just one brief example from
the nation that's the that's made from
the nation in which I was born many
Hindus Buddhists and Jains believe that
all of life is holy and should be
unharmed all animals and some vegetables
they share a society India with about a
hundred and forty million Muslims who
believe that slaughtering goats on
certain holy uncertain days as Holy and
eating meat on most other days is a very
good idea how can these groups with such
basic differences anchored and cosmic
convictions share a society together
these are the kinds of questions that
Michael Walzer Alfred Stefan and George
and John courtney marie asked in their
works of political theory finally
sociology what do we know from people
doing empirical work both ethnographic
and quantitative about how communities
who orient differently around religion
might get along Robert Putnam and David
Campbell's American grace asks the
question how America as a nation that is
both religiously diverse and religiously
devout has remained largely
quote-unquote tolerant even during times
of religious tension and conflict
elsewhere pax ethnic a' takes an
ethnographic look at a range of highly
diverse cities around the world and asks
what makes places like flushing or
marsai largely cooperative Brown
University professor ashutosh Varshney
has a hugely important study of India
called ethnic conflict and civic life in
which he asks the question why do some
cities in India remain calm during times
of communal tension when other cities
explode in violence the answer is
surprisingly simple the existence of
civic networks Rotary clubs and the like
that bring people from different
backgrounds together on a regular basis
seems to be the single biggest
difference between stability and
violence that answer incidentally
highlights why I am calling this a
program and interfaith leadership civic
networks that bring will that bring
diverse people together don't fall from
the sky somebody starts them somebody
continues them they are built by people
by leaders a second course in this
sequence would be case studies and
religious violence and interfaith peace
building this course would present
actual instances of religious diversity
becoming either conflict or cooperation
and analyzing the role that leaders
played in either fanning the flames of
conflict or building the bridges of
cooperation text would include mark
Jergens Meyers terror in the mind of God
the multi-volume fundamentalism project
by Scott Appleby and Martin Marty David
smocks interfaith dialogue and peace
building and interfaith case studies
developed by harvard's pluralism project
key leadership texts by scholars like
Ronnie heifetz and Howard Gardner would
also be employed
case studies would include everything
from how Osama bin Laden mobilized a set
of Muslims to build a religious
extremist organization like al-qaeda to
how Martin Luther King jr. mobilized
racially and religiously diverse people
to build a civil rights movement some
case studies would come right off the
front pages of the New York Times and
students would be asked if you were in
Grand Island Nebraska when latina when
African American Christians staged a
walkout of a factory because the Somali
Muslim workers had recently won a
schedule change to accommodate Ramadan
hours how would you lead in that
community that question how would you
lead would be at the heart of the
discussion in this class akin to the
Harvard Business School key study model
which presents students were the real
life situations faced by companies and
asked them what they would do if they
were in charge this course would
constantly be asking the students how
would you strengthen interfaith
cooperation in this particular case when
diversity seems to be tending towards
conflict a third course I would require
is something along the lines of
perspectives and religion in some ways
this is a typical course offered in most
religious studies departments on the
nature of religion with readings by Jose
Casanova Talal Asad Clifford Geertz
Mircea Eliade Wilfred can't Will Smith
Marshall Hudson Peter Berger Rudolf Otto
Paul Tillich Houston Smith Steven
Prather on the classics Marc Faber and
Durkheim students would examine various
theories of religion autos notion that
at the center of religion is an
experience that is wholly other
something he calls the numinous telex
view that what religion is really about
is ultimate concerns Cantwell Smith's
writings on religion being best
understood as cumulative historical
traditions and the term faith being best
defined is the relationship that
individuals and communities have with
various dimensions of that tradition
burgers emphasis on institution as the
plausibility structures that pattern
human activity and its key insight that
what modernity really does is plural
eyes moving personal identity from fate
to choice making the internal life of
human beings far more complex now than
in pre-modern times
students would put scholars like Houston
Smith and Stephen Protheroe into
dialogue with each other our religion is
actually quite similar as Smith suggests
or really very different as Prothero
rights this course will widen
perspectives and debunk common myths
like the idea that Sacred Scripture
somehow gets up and walks around by
itself with no assistance from human
interpreters the final course I would
require is a course called theologies of
interfaith cooperation students would
read theologians and ethicists from a
range of faiths including secular
humanism who advance interpretations and
narratives of their traditions that
speak to positive relationship building
with the other this would include
holiday abu el fuddle fatigue SI umar
abdullah fazlur rahman and ingrid Matson
out of the slum Jonathan Sacks or Rose
mark open and Abraham Joshua Heschel out
of Judaism Mahatma Gandhi and Swami
Vivekananda from Hinduism Paul knitter
and Hans küng from Catholicism Miroslav
Volf and Brian McLaren from Protestant
evangelical Christianity the key
question of the course would be how have
theologians from a range of traditions
stitched together interpretations of
Scripture stories heroes and historical
moments from their key sources to
articulate a coherent narrative of
positive relationship with the religious
other and how do they navigate some of
the most challenging and complex
questions what do jewish theologians do
with the idea of chosen pneus in
relating to the religious other how do
we evangelicals view the idea of Christ
as the exclusive path to salvation in
light of admiring the spiritual example
of someone like the Dalai Lama or Gandhi
the core idea here is that positive
relations between those who orient
around religion differently does not
require leaving religion aside some of
the great interfaith leaders of the 20th
century Gandhi and King to name two
obvious ones build bridges with people
of other faiths precisely because of
their respective and Hindu and Christian
faiths not despite them interfaith
leaders need to be fluent in the
theology of interfaith cooperation of
their own tradition and literate in such
theologies in other
ditions after this after this for course
sequence I would require two electives
that could be taken from a range of
options some students might want to do a
deeper dive into religion by taking
courses in Christianity Islam Buddhism
etc some might want to focus in a
particular region the middle east or
south asia the capstone project would be
one of two things that is one the design
and implementation of a local interfaith
project that puts into practice key
theories and skills of interfaith
leadership learn through the coursework
or two to write a program proposal for
dealing with an interfaith challenge
elsewhere in the country or world the
key requirement in both cases is that
they must make use of interfaith leaders
in civil society to build pluralism out
of diversity as I conclude I want to
return to the place where I started in
the mighty in the Almighty secretary
Albright noted when I was Secretary of
State I had an entire bureau of economic
experts I could turn to and a cadre of
experts and non-proliferation and arms
control I did not have similar expertise
available for integrating religious
principles into our efforts at diplomacy
it's an important reminder that foreign
policy is ultimately not carried out by
paradigms it's carried out by people
this is the reason that the program I'm
outlining above emphasizes nurturing
leaders when those leaders graduate they
will need jobs and I think one of the
places that ought to hire them is the
State Department but it's far from the
only place staff of international
development organizations World Vision
USAID islamic relief that are attempting
to spread polio vaccines in south asia
or anti-malarial bed nets in sub-saharan
africa better be aware of their
religious energies in those places YMCA
executive directors and school
principals and inner city Minneapolis
would do well to know something about
the faith practices of the Somali
Muslims the Hmong shamaness and
practitioners of Native American
religions in the surrounding area
city officials in rapidly diversifying
cities like Atlanta Houston and
Birmingham should have some knowledge of
the hindu customs of their indian
population and it would be a double
tragedy if the first time that
journalists from Milwaukee news outlets
visited the local Sikh temple was in the
immediate aftermath of a white
supremacist shooting six people there I
think it's useful to say a few words
about what I have chosen to emphasize in
my imagined program and what is left out
this is a program of study that focuses
on how communities who orient around
religion differently are going to relate
to one another within cities nations
regions in the world at large and it
seeks to nurture leaders who are able to
build bridges between these different
groups the emphasis is on the public
dimension of religion how its narratives
promote conflict or cooperation how its
social capital is mobilized towards
violence or community building there is
little in what I have articulated above
that deals with personal and pastoral
matters things having to do with
people's spiritual journeys personal
sins the religious symbolism of their
wedding ceremonies I think it is fair to
say that most of the current interest in
interfaith cooperation is the latter the
personal the pastoral the spiritual
memoir is probably the most common genre
and the literature of the movement
personal story telling is amongst the
most common practices questions about
one's own religious or spiritual
identity in relation with others and
personal pastoral intimate ways are
always highly salient at interfaith
gatherings not only is this to be
expected it's beautiful it is the human
family figuring out its next steps and
an era of frequent and intense
interactions with people of different
identities to paraphrase Wilfred can't
Will Smith if faith is to be lived at
all in the future it will be lived in
intimate relations with others but if
life is to be lived at all in the future
it will be lived in cities nations and
regions that are highly diverse and if
leaders who are making faith a bomb of
destruction continue to win then the
various intimacy's
of more prosaic interfaith existence
what it means to date or marry someone
from a different community how to raise
children and a multi religious household
are moot I think the civic and political
questions around religious diversity are
so challenging and the need to nurture a
critical mass of leaders who can build
pluralism out of diversity in the public
square so great that tilting the
academic dimensions of this field of
interfaith studies towards the public
square rather than the private sphere is
warranted I should hasten to add that
these types of programs are growing as
well at places like the Brookley Center
at Georgetown the Kroc Institute in
order Dame right here in the faith and
globalization program at Yale and many
of these are funded by the loose
foundation moreover precisely because
personal pastoral and spiritual matters
are so present in prevalent
conversations around the private matters
of interfaith existence or happening an
expertise in this area is building
college chaplain sees around the
vanguard of this and it is no surprise
because people like Sharon Coogler Omar
bajwa and the rest of the chaplaincy
here at Yale are constantly dealing with
the personal questions of young people
figuring out their identities in
relation to people of other identities
hospitals wedding halls pastor spiritual
writers and counselors all of these
individuals and institutions are growing
quite expert at dealing with interfaith
questions and people's personal pastoral
and spiritual lives and unsurprisingly
there are academic programs that are
emerging to train to train professionals
and what I'm calling the more private
sphere of interfaith existence in some
ways this is a response to a market
people require the services of
institutions and individuals who can
engage their private needs around the
intersection of personal spiritual
identity and diversity and it is all to
the good what I fear is that as the
literature expertise in programs in this
area grow the field of interfaith
studies will begin to look like an
endeavor focused mostly on the private
domain the Civic and political questions
of how groups who orient around religion
differently will continue to be engaged
but in separate departments and journals
and programs of study as they are now
without the benefit of cooperation and
connection without the benefit of a
field so let me end with the obvious
that the issues around interfaith
studies are both about private lives and
the public sphere and one key question
is how to connect the two a Jewish
undergraduate may first become
interested in interfaith cooperation
because she is dating a Hindu or finds
the spiritual discipline of a Muslim to
be inspiring by taking the concentration
I outline above she will hopefully have
more knowledge and skills with which to
navigate her private life and also the
expertise to build pluralism out of
diversity in the realm of civil society
and politics and I'll end with an image
and a quote from martin luther king jr.
which is I think the ultimate goal of
this endeavor he called it the world
house and he imagined humankind is a
large family who had received an
inheritance this single house and
imagined us all going there on this
island and looking at each other and
realizing that we are black and white
Eastern Westerner Protestant and
Catholic Gentile and you and all of us
because we can never again live apart
have to somehow learn to live in this
house in peace that house needs
architects those architects need
training that's why we need a field of
interfaith studies thank
well thank you for initiating such a
such a what I hope will be continuing
discussion here of these of these things
with such a well put together and both
provocative and in many ways though
persuasive I talk we do have about 20 25
minutes or so for questions and comments
I will resist the temptation to to use
the prerogative of the chair to ask the
first question but I have one which I
yes why don't you say who you are oh my
name is a ruby de Silva EBU people okay
I had a question about a space of
experience than the community organizer
community can you give the examples of
how maybe you went about really not just
interested maybe excitement I think
that's a great question thank you for
that question so this is I i think it's
it's two categories right once a
knowledge base and the other is a skill
set and and I think in doing in in
building bridges between religious
communities and the geeky term for this
is is bridging social capital between
community to orient around religion
differently is you have to know have
appreciative knowledge of those other
communities you have to be able to walk
into a mosque synagogue or Church an
evangelical space and be able to
articulate what you admire about that
tradition the ability to say you know I
have great admiration for the way
evangelicals build international relief
organizations that begins with knowledge
right is is the is is is simply knowing
those things and one of the the
interesting things is the prevalence of
the category religious literacy over the
past eight or ten years bye bye Stephen
Prothero one of the one of them I think
I think religious literacy is a hugely
important project I just think it's
incomplete adjust the facts approach
along the lines of religiously
rocee doesn't cultivate the kind of
appreciation and admiration I think that
we need to live in a multi religious
society give you a quick example of this
so to know the facts of a racially
diverse society might be to know that
twelve percent of America is
african-american but actually I would
hope that people know more than that I
would hope that people know the great
inventions by black scientists the great
literature by african-american writers
the great feats by black athletes etc
etc etc I think we need the same
knowledge base when it comes to to a
multi religious society and I think that
being being an organizer or an
interfaith leader begins with having
that knowledge base the other thing is
having the skill set to be able to
articulate those things to folks so so
the skill isn't is in having the
language to mobilize people based on the
dimensions of their traditions that they
find important mercy in Islam justice
and Judaism love and Christianity the
knowledge base to know the particular
stories and scripture around those key
values and the skills to be able to tell
the stories that would bring folks from
those communities into whatever project
you're interested in
particularly envisioned us to start
integrating this yeah so I think that
that's hugely important and honestly I'm
just not smart enough to have gotten to
that yet and I'm being very serious
about that right so so the you know I've
spent the last 10 years building an
organization called interfaith youth
core and we focus on college campuses
and every sector of society has its own
quirks and idiosyncrasies and and
working with college campuses is its own
set of practices quirks and
idiosyncrasies the quote-unquote
barriers to entry and college campuses
of our of a particular type the barriers
to entry in secular secondary schools or
of a second type right so my hope is
that a field of interfaith cooperation
would be much broader than an academic
field of interfaith studies it would
include all sorts of nonprofit
organizations one of which would focus
on on interfaith literacy interfaith
cooperation in secondary schools it's
just not going to be my organization at
this point in its history there are some
good resources on this though and I'll
just give you a couple off the top off
the top of my head so Charles Haynes at
the First Amendment Center has done a
great little monograph on a city in
California Modesto that implemented a
world religions a world religions course
and it's kind of a great a great little
book on how that on how that went and a
second is Diane more who's at at Harvard
Divinity School who focuses on religious
diversity and religious literacy in
secondary school so i would i would
check those out
I love it yeah thank you for that
question I think it's a terrific
question and it's it's it's one that
some smart person in just about every
audience that i gave a talk to ask so
thank you for being that's my person in
this audience so so the answer to the
question actually do a little bit of
backtracking and say when I when I kind
of first conceived of interfaith youth
core in the late 1990s and early 2000s I
wasn't smart enough to include secular
humanists in it and secular humanists
kept showing up at the table and frankly
having some of the skills of interfaith
leadership that I spoke about with you a
knowledge base of different traditions a
skill set of storytelling mobilizing
facilitating that were as good if not
better than some of the religious folks
around the table so finally you know I
just woke up and I was like well you're
you're already at the table you excel
here I need to create a theory of this
work that includes you I think that
that's that's one of the reasons that I
use the language people who orient
around religion differently rather than
the language of religious diversity or
religious identity a slight shift but
you folks at Yale appreciate such slide
shifts in language I understand so I
think secular humanists are at the table
just like anybody else's and where the
rubber meets the road in this work right
is are you able to build bridges between
people who orient around religion
differently that's where the rubber
meets the road so the
our model for this is not is not a
representational model it's not like you
know the joke is the it's not a guy's
and funny hats model right it's it's a
social entrepreneur model where what
we're trying to do is inspire nurture
educate train a critical mass of people
who can go into the public square and
and build civic bridges between groups
orient around religion differently
whether you're a Hindu or a humanist or
an evangelical a Catholic the only thing
that matters is you are able to mobilize
the resources of your tradition towards
to where it's implementing that towards
that skill set so let me give you two
books I'm feeling very professorial here
so Greg Epstein who's the humanist
chaplain at Harvard has a book called
good without god which which articulates
a positive relational view of humanism
and a great book a memoir called faithy
'used by a guy named Chris Stedman just
came out which I just wrote the forward
to actually which which does the same
thing and then let me just as as we are
at a place that that has a high view of
language let me let me just draw in red
marker around the term unity our view of
this is it's not about unity it's about
relationships and one of the things I
was saying the professorship hero
earlier is that my favorite new line is
is a diverse democracy depends upon
people who have deep disagreements on
some important things recognizing and
working on their commonality and other
important things right so evangelicals
and Muslims view Jesus differently and
view many issues in the world
differently just because they have
differences and on a B and C shouldn't
mean that they can't work together on XY
and Z and in my view the work of
building pluralism is recognizing where
differences are and working together on
commonality and I just don't know how
you have a diverse democracy without
that
one of the disc and you say where you
are yes Steve you go I sometimes feel
what I'm among sociologists religion and
people more politically oriented but
they sort of slice off you know their
lair of this issue and it's like what
most of us do we pick out what stabs
familiar to us so I was like that when
you brought this issue of this
fragmentation and I want I wonder if you
had contact yeah fox cub how you would
bring in these immense resources of
comparative theologians and people have
involved in inter-religious dialogue for
50 years like on a car yeah Catherine
corneal it Franklin right most people oh
you are you are so close to my heart
right now these are my favorite people
yes from social psychology about how you
put together groups that are divided in
groups yeah yeah yeah I think this is
huge so so this is one of the reasons
that I outlined a course a program of
study right and and the four courses
that I would require in my geeky vision
of this are two courses are about the
role of public religion in the world to
to quote Casanova right and two are very
much about what will adjust about the
heart of religious traditions Rudolph
Otto Paul Tillich Cantwell Smith in a
principles of religion and the
perspectives on a religion course and
then a course on theologies of
interfaith cooperation so I think I
think if I had one this isn't a critique
this is a marriage I think what you're
proposing is a marriage right I think
you're right that that there are plenty
of sociologists of religion who view
religion instrumentally as simply
repositories of social capital and the
way they talk about them to religious
people and people who work
with religious traditions feels
functionalist feels instrumentalist
right and this is actually I did um I
did a talk at Harvard Divinity School a
few months ago that Frank Clooney was
the chair of and he said to me that the
Kennedy School folks had been you know
calling over to the Divinity School more
and more to say can you bring your
religion types here because we're
recognizing the importance of religion
in politics and the public square and
Frank Clooney who is you know maybe the
nation's most prominent comparative
theologian says I'm only going to come
if you take religion seriously right you
have to convince me that you understand
that this is about like the deepest
heartfelt motivations of large swathes
of humankind it's not just about moving
lines on maps on the other hand and I've
had this conversation with Professor
Clooney if the the people who are able
to look at the role that religion plays
in the public square have the types of
methodologies and paradigms that you
hint at paradigms of cooperation versus
conflict etc that can in fact be very
powerful and useful I think that the
bridge here is in what we at interfaith
youth core call a theology of interfaith
cooperation which is to say to a frank
Clooney listen with in religions are
theologies are resources that articulate
how within that tradition it is of great
significance to participate positively
in a diverse public square this is why
we you know seven of the eight Ivy
League schools were founded by religious
communities right there are 230 Catholic
universities in America these are
institutions founded out of the
inspiration of a particular heritage
that engage positively in diverse public
square so I think the bridge between
people who whose particular focus is
religious traditions and people whose
particular focus is the sociology of
religion is a theology of interfaith
cooperation that comes within different
traditions that applies itself to but
what can we do in terms of our daily
activities you're interacting so I would
do I mean I think I think that in a lot
of ways the pedagogy of the interfaith
studies program that I laid out is is
more similar to business school pedagogy
than anything else and I hinted at it in
the talk right you take particular case
studies of communities that are whose
religious diversity is tending towards
conflict just as you would you would
take in a business school setting you
would take a case study of a company
that was hemorrhaging revenue or
hemorrhaging clients and you wouldn't
ask the question of your CEO of this
company what would you do wait you would
ask the question in Grand Island
Nebraska when Somali Muslims staged a
walkout because the schedule of the
factory that they worked in was not
accommodating Robin odd hours and won a
concession and then in response the
Latino and African American Christians
staged a walkout because the concession
meant to shift in the schedule such that
they received 15 minutes less pay if you
were a pastor in that in Grand Island
Nebraska what's the sermon you would
preach on Sunday right so I think one
answer to your question is to is to ask
very real case study questions of when
an area of religious diversity
loads in the conflict what would you do
as a leader what do you do in and
democratizing my and Mar and part of the
definition of democracy is the ability
of groups to articulate their goals in
the public square instead of simply a
state kind of suffocating everything
what do you do in democratizing Miami
what if you were on sun suchi and your
primary focus was on elections and all
of a sudden this this violence erupts
between Buddhists and Muslims in a
region of my and Mar how much attention
which you pay to that what what speech
would you give the following week about
that right a case study model I think
the second thing that you're the second
part of your question the second half of
it is in our kind of prosaic existence
in our day-to-day existence what can we
do to deal with interfaith cooperation
so here's an example of this the fact is
religious prejudice is rife in our
culture and and it's almost off hand and
it's it was definitely off hand during
the presidential election and if you're
in Mississippi the comments about Barack
Obama being a secret muslim are probably
not that strange and if you're in New
Haven there's a reasonable chance of
comments about Mitt Romney's magic
underwear and Mormonism are probably not
that strange and I think part of what
you do as an interfaith leader is you
know that that prejudice exists and you
have the knowledge base and language to
deal with it right so at the dinner
table look if somebody said something
biased about South Asians or East Asians
or black folks or gays or lesbians in a
place like Cambridge Massachusetts or
New Haven Connecticut people would have
the knowledge base in language and kind
of radar screen to deal with it but i
watch religious prejudice go unchecked
all the time right and it's simply a
matter of do people realize when
somebody somebody somebody says in an
airport security line as I heard this
morning mad that there was a backup in
the security line damn Muslims I'm like
really dude you know it it's a kind of
thing in various in different ways in
various regions is simply part of dinner
table conversation I think part of what
we can do is have a radar screen for
those things and check them i'm going to
give you a great example of this so did
anybody happen to catch walter currents
essay on the Mormon community in the New
Republic some months ago really really
beautiful SI and Walter Kirn of course
the great American writer wrote
thumbsucker wrote up in the air he got
tired of hearing in you know New York or
New York Times type media these kind of
snide comments about Mormons and so he
wrote this beautiful article about how
during a really challenging time during
his his adolescence when his family was
breaking apart they converted for a
period of time to to LDS and and
although the family moved away from it
after some time that experience of
several years in the church had a
dramatic strengthening effect within the
family and he was like look I wish that
Charles blow who made an offhand you
know who's a New York Times column it's
why quite like most of the time made an
offhand prejudicial reference to Mitt
Romney's magic underwear he's like I
wish that Charles blow would view Mormon
identity as something that is that
deserves the same respect as Catholic or
humanist or Muslim or black or gay
identity so that's the kind of thing I
think all of us can do on a regular
basis
I wonder to what extent the party has
chapters yeah so that's a great question
so actually five years ago three years
ago I would have happily told you all of
our international work and interfaith
youth core and then we went through a
strategic plan and part of what the
group of folks who did this regime plan
said to us is listen you guys are spread
way too thin and you think you're you
know you are quite impressed with
yourselves because you can say you've
got stuff in Jordan and Israel and and
india etc but the fact is you're not
doing a good job anywhere so you have 35
staff and a 4 million dollar budget and
what you really ought to do is choose an
area to focus and try to build actual
effective models in that area and so we
did a lot of pulling back and it's not
because we don't love going to India or
Jordan or Israel it's because we need to
have a critical mass of impact somewhere
and we've chosen that critical massive
impact to be on us college campuses and
there's you know a bunch of good reasons
for that campuses as many civil
societies campuses as places that
nurture our societies leaders etc and
it's got nothing to do with other places
not being important it's just got
something to do with limited resources
and the need to focus I will say that I
you know may there be dozens of
interfaith organizations that focus on
effective programs in all parts of the
world our challenge for right now is us
college campuses and college students
Yeah Yeah right yes okay okay super
important question and and I think a
very a very compelling view so you're
asking a question in your offering of
view right of what the common good might
be or a process to get to that right so
I have spent some amount of time
thinking about this in the past couple
years and i want to i think that this is
exactly why literature and perspectives
from political theory are critically
important for for a program and
interfaith studies is because people in
different societies view the common good
very very differently obviously and i
have a particular view of of gun issues
and other people have other views right
we share the same society now that
actually means some basic but profound
things we pay taxes to the same
government when leaders get elected we
recognize that those leaders are
empowered for a particular period of
time to make laws etc etc etc right we
convene around the same symbols
passports and at american flags whatever
it might be so this is all to say that I
think in when I use the term common good
it has to be an idea of the common good
that is broadly shared as opposed to
something that is particular so you know
one a term that political theorists and
scientists often use is what's the
lapping consensus for this okay so what
I am when I say common good right now
part of what I mean is is basic state
institutions that we all recognize are
necessary for all of us to function and
thrive a police force garbage collectors
that in other societies in which
particular communities are disempowered
the state institutions didn't pick up
the garbage in Shia areas of Iraq at the
same rate that they picked up the
garbage in Sunni areas of Iraq under
Saddam Hussein so part of what Shias did
was create their own civic institutions
that did that kind of work for them
right when Saddam is toppled those civic
institutions can easily be turned into
effectively tribal armies we can't have
that happen in diverse democracies we
have to recognize that Muslims
Christians and Jews have an investment
in the common good of police forces
garbage collectors etc etc that take
care of basic functionality for all of
us now that's a really prosaic thing
here's a higher level thing civil rights
right then that we recognize that
there's no such thing as Muslims civil
rights in America or Jewish civil rights
or african-american civil rights there
are civil rights that belong to all of
us and that that is part of the common
good of America and each community has a
stake in supporting those broader common
good principles that then protect all of
us does that does that make sense I
haven't fully I don't have all the
language for this yet but what I'm
pretty convinced of is that you can't
have a definition of the common good
that large swathes of people don't agree
on don't agree on you have to have a
definition even if it's things as
prosaic as we different communities are
not going to invest in our own police
force which by the way is no small thing
there are plenty of developing countries
in which different particularistic
immunities and basically have civic
institutions that serve the needs of
their community and at times of communal
violence those Civic institutions the
boys that you know on Sunday morning
we're picking up garbage on Tuesday
afternoon are carrying pitchforks right
so that idea of the common good
everything from functionally functioning
institutions that all of us contribute
to to broader principles that benefit
all of us it seems to me is very
important
Yeah right yeah this is why you come to
Yale to give talked right because you
get questions like this thank you for
this I mean these questions are going to
keep me up nights so it depends on your
definition of unity right and and what I
am what I am suggesting is that the
difference that that that the term unity
frequently means large large amounts of
agreement on large amounts of things
right and I'm suggesting that the term
relationship means you and I can talk
about x y&z really positively and
recognize that a B and C we're going to
argue about so sometimes I'll bring that
up and sometimes we'll just leave it off
the table right so what what I'm saying
and it is Michael Walzer has this
beautiful line that the the challenge of
a diverse society is to embrace its
differences and maintain a common life
I've probably meditated on that line for
12 years right what does that line mean
and the best that I can do is that it it
means there's basic respect for the
identities of different communities and
individuals within a society in other
words there's a sense that we you know
look if you live in Afghanistan and
you're a Hazara you have a basic sense
that people hate you and people
disrespect you if you live in Pakistan
and you're an Ahmadi you have a sense
that people hate you right that is not a
good thing for a society it's a terrible
thing of your part of that community
it's also a terrible thing for the
society a diverse society cultivates a
basic sense of respect appreciation and
knowledge base for its diverse
communities and this by the way is
obvious right I mean you know I used to
watch a lot of ESPN SportsCenter I have
a five-year-old which means I watched a
lot of dora and diego and and
Nickelodeon jr. and you know they're
there is a multi cultural themes our
front and center that from which i think
is a really good thing from the get-go
our society even on commercial
television is teaching kids the
appreciation of spanish language words
right probably half the shows and
Nickelodeon jr. have explicit
multicultural themes little bill right
like even the fret i mean any of you
have young kids is this like you know
what I'm talking about Mira do you let
your kids watch TV some look I'm The
Fresh Beat Band you know the guitar
player is the guitar player the
drummer's the girl and the MC is the
white guy like that's deliberate right
people were we're cultivating a sense of
of multicultural appreciation in our
society so respect and appreciation of
diverse identities is part one
relationships between different
communities as part two and a commitment
to the common good the sense that a
strong America both in simply its
functionality and in its principles
benefits all of us and therefore we have
some commitment to that in the form of
tax dollars in the form of voting in the
form of a robust notion of citizenship
Mira asked me a hard question
yeah yeah yeah so I just want a book
called Sega ground in the last chapter
of the book is called American Muslim
child which is about you know stories of
like of is 8 so I'll tell one quick
story which I tell in that chapter so
we're at our secular Hindu neighbors
house for diwali and my son who's 3 at
the Times aide says bismillah r-rahman
r-rahim before eating which I am so
thrilled about you know I'm like he's
knows it he says that he says it outside
of the home then he looks at his Hindu
friend the rune and he's like you have
to say bismillah before eating you know
and then in the room like knows how to
play this game he's like I'm not saying
its aid so what does they do says it
louder right you have to say and I swear
to God the ruins parents look at shahnaz
and me and they're like we thought you
weren't those type of Muslims you know
and i'm like saying to my son and like
you know 60 people and they're like most
fabulous indian gear are like staring at
my three-year-old shouting at the rune
you have to say bismillah and so you
know zaid gets up and starts like taking
off across the room like this is not
good so I intercept my son and I whisper
in his ear by the way my wife is like
shooting me this like steely-eyed look
you know like I brought the cupcakes
you're the religion guy you take care of
this you know and and I like just come
kind of comes out of me I say I say to
zaid we're saying bismillah fourth the
road right and and what what occurs to
me you know five hours later in that
like small space when you get to think
as a parent you know which is about 20
minutes long every day
is what I have to teach my kid is that
he comes from a particular religious
tradition that has something to say
about relationships with people from
other religions and and yes there are
very hard conversations to have you know
we believe that that the Shahada and and
and Islam is the is the fullness of
truth right we also believe that having
the fullness of truth means certain
responsibilities and certain ways of
relating with people who are different
and that is a huge part of the
definition of being Muslim so you know I
imagine that when zaid gets a lot you
know a lot older there's meaning eight
nine ten we're going to have to have
question you know we sentence a to say
another quick quick funny story so we
sense age of a Catholic preschool which
takes Catholicism quite seriously which
we were happy about you know lord's
prayer before meals PA announcements on
the Saints etc and so one day we're it
were in the park and zaid sees a statue
and he thinks it's the statue that's
associated with this local coffee shop
called julius meinl so he says I'm going
to go look at julius meinl it runs over
there and he says mommy it's not julius
meinl it's Jesus you know like the whole
park is staring at us right and I'm like
you know my son is able to like identify
a hundred different types of Jesus
statues you know I I view that as part
of being a Muslim owner of religiously
diverse society in other words it Islam
has ideas of positive relation ality
which are ingrained in the tradition and
my job is to emphasize those things does
that solve the other hard problems no I
don't think so but I think what it does
is it gives us a fulcrum of emphasis of
how you can be both particular within a
tradition and that's really important to
me right is that it's it's not i'm not
saying it has to be important to anybody
to everybody but it's important to me
for my children to know that you you are
part of a particular tradition not just
some some universal spirituality then
you're you are part of islam of 1400
year old tradition the tradition of you
ancestors and being part of that
tradition means something for how you
relate to people from other traditions
you know you want to come to an
interfaith Leadership Institute
basically what what what we do a huge
part of the organization does is we run
for interfaith leadership Institute's a
year we're doing one in two weeks in
Atlanta I'll be super impressed if you
can get it together to get to that but
you know we did one at USC a few months
ago we did we do one in Chicago every
summer which is where we base were based
and it's delegations of students from
different campuses across the country
who come and do kind of a four day
intensive in the knowledge base and
skill set of interfaith leadership and
the chaplaincy here you know ought to
pay for you to come you you in a
delegation Omar bhadra who is the Muslim
chaplain was here earlier but see me
afterwards but I fyc org under
interfaith leadership Institute's and
you know students from 150 or 200
campuses to have come to these things
yeah so I think that's a great question
so so and I think it's related to the
question that was asked earlier so cool
so I think in a couple ways one if you
proactively identify as a secular
humanist or then then which you are part
of what you are doing is proactively
placing yourself within a tradition that
has an awful lot to say about diverse
democracies positive relations with
different communities etc etc etc right
so so in a way that's easy and we get a
lot of those too I think so second
category of things to say there are two
doorways into interfaith youth core or
interfaith stuff in general doorway
number one is personal identity this
matters to me as a Hindu or a Jew or a
humanist or any medical or Catholic
doorway number two is civil society and
politics this might not matter to me and
my personal identity but it matters in
the public sphere and therefore i'm
interested so I think nuns what would be
able to walk through either or both of
those doors the first one they have to
they have to articulate for themselves
in what ways do they have a personal
stake in interfaith cooperation right
they might do it from a perspective of
humanism they might do it from a
perspective of spirituality they might
they might not care about religion at
all but they're tired of having their
Mormon and Muslim friends maligned and
that gives them a personal stake I think
two is you know part of the definition
of being an educated and active citizen
is this issue is going to matter and
developing knowledge and skills around
it or just are good for the purpose of
being educated and active in a
democratic society is it
yeah I mean I really think so yeah this
is this is it from my point of view I
think this is the question you're asking
if it's not correct me this is
theologies of interfaith cooperation
right this is the ability to stitch
together scripture stories heroes
historical moments etc etc from the key
sources of a particular tradition that
ask and answer the question how do I
relate to the religious other right by
the way these stories obviously exist
we're not making them up i'll give a key
story in just a moment but i'll say in
my view of theologies of interfaith
cooperation are analogous to theologies
of environmentalism or theologies of
racial reconciliation in this way that
they have for a long time existed within
traditions but its particular the needs
of particular historical moments that
make them more salient so during the
1950s and 1960s during during the
apartheid years in South Africa for
example there were theologians who came
up with things like the Kairos document
right which was what Christianity had to
say about about about different races
right during the civil rights movement
there was a lot of theology on there was
a lot of multiracial theology and
theologies of Rachel's the
reconciliation because the historic
historical moment called for it we're in
a historical moment that requires people
to articulate a theology of interfaith
cooperation it's not that these things
don't exist right it read miroslava
encounter and embrace read anything that
Paul knitter has written read anything
that Hans küng is written I think the
difference is and this is this is also a
story I tell in my book sacred ground if
I were to ask any of you Divinity School
students what's your theology of poverty
you will be able to quote me chapter and
verse right in part biggest liberation
theology from the time of Gustavo
Gutierrez you know forward has been
highly salient and in part because you
care about it and divinity schools teach
it if I were to say what's your theology
of interfaith cooperation and I ask this
question and of course I taught at
Princeton Theological Seminary i had 45
students staring at me like I they never
heard the term before it's it's a matter
of having that narrative salient well
I'll give one quick example of this
simply to illustrate how this is not
something we have to make up or graft on
to our religions how it's at the heart
of it so you know when I when I teach in
seminaries or divinity schools the and I
say what's your favorite Bible story
four out of five people will say the
Good Samaritan story right so the
classic of course what's what's the Good
Samaritan story the lawyer asks Jesus
how do i attain eternal life Jesus says
you know how to do this love love God
and love your neighbor as yourself who
is my neighbor right and of course Jesus
tells the story of the Good Samaritan
what's the story traveler left for dead
by the side of the road who passes him
by two liters of his own faith the
priest and the Levite who stops the
Samaritan stops dresses the man's wounds
with oil and wine puts him on his mule
takes him to an inn etc etc who is this
American frequently talked about as the
other or the marginalized one but
there's something more specific he's not
just the other he's the religious other
he's a person from a different religious
community and we know that Jesus
disagrees with that other religion
because elsewhere in the Bible there's
the story of the woman at the well Jesus
articulates I have a different theology
you have the wrong theology so what's
Jesus saying in this story don't follow
the ethic of the people whose theology
you disagree with when they leave the
traveler by the side of the road follow
the ethic of the person whose theology
you disagree with right that's a story
at the heart of the Christian
tradition the notion of follow to follow
the Samaritan follow the religious other
when their ethic when their ethic is
more beautiful than the ethic of the
ones of your own faith that's just one
example of kind of a key text within a
theology of interfaith cooperation
Jewish we take two of them together and
then I'll be short yeah you will take
both of you together and then I'll
answer the easiest one yes that's
probably the harder question so
oh yes as a great quiz are both great
questions okay i will attempt to be as
brief as possible so here is the biggest
trick I know learn what you admire about
other traditions and tell those people
that regardless of what they start with
the single most important knowledge and
skill and interfaith cooperation learn
things you admire about other faiths
songs that you like in there in there
canon of songs pieces of scripture that
you appreciate heroes that you admire I
learn those things and when you when you
are in an interfaith encounter in which
it's warranted talk about them Cokie
Roberts and NPR had this great line the
other day when analysis of politics she
was like let me tell you Bill Clinton's
secret it's very hard to dislike someone
who likes you and who tells you they
like you and who tells you what they
like about you right so look I I enter
into interface situations as a Muslim
and as a smart and as an aspiring Muslim
right not not particularly I'm not
necessarily set up to be well-liked by
broad swats of people my bag of tricks
is I know what I admire about the LDS
Church about evangelicals about secular
humanists about Catholics about Jews and
it's not made up you know it's not like
it's not I don't view it as a bag of
tricks I view it as as part of my part
of my responsibilities and part of my
privilege as a human being and isn't as
a citizen to learn about things that I
admire of people from other traditions
and notice I'll just double click on
that for one second and then get to your
question notice that if are there any
religious studies scholars in this room
people who like read dead languages for
example okay there was nothing in that
there was nothing in my program of study
about
that okay so i think that to be an
effective interfaith leader you need a
particular knowledge base of other
traditions and that knowledge base is on
this side of knowing sanskrit poly in
Greek right it is it is in it is in
having than having the type of knowledge
and skills that enables you to build
relationships with people from other
backgrounds that a good bridge to that
next question right so yes relationships
are hard so I will offer a very prosaic
illustration every evening i come home
at six o'clock and i have two choices to
make do I want to get along with my wife
or do I not want to get along with my
wife and it's actually it's it's like
literally and in front of me choice if I
talk about these sets of things I will
not get along with my wife if I talk
about these sets of things I will get
along with my wife now sometimes
circumstances are such or I am stupid
and I will somehow talk about these sets
of thing this set of things but i I've
now been married for 10 years happily
glowingly etc and probably the single
most important thing I've learned is I
make a choice in how I relate to my wife
every day I know the topics of
conversation the times of those topics
the tone of those topics that are likely
to put two to have to be enriching happy
etc and I know when it's not going to be
right so and when I say relationship I
mean civic relationship I think perhaps
you are five layers deeper in the rabbit
hole in I I mean the type of
relationship that would have me look at
somebody that I know I disagree with on
really important things and I'm making
the decision to speak about what I
admired from that tradition and the
kinds of things that we can do well and
profit
together and I'm making the decision
that we're going to have X type of
relationship instead of Y type of
relationship at that moment now I will
say one one final thing about this this
is where the private and the public and
that split is really really important
okay I do not feel I'm going to be
provocative about this and then we can
fight at the reception deal that's what
receptions are for this is precisely why
I'm articulating interfaith leadership
as a civic public political endeavor
whose purpose is to build relationships
between people in the public square as
opposed to a private or personal
endeavor if I learn for example when I
spoke at a relatively conservative
mosque some years ago the guy who hosted
me was like man you got to take your
earrings out took my earrings out right
that was an easy decision for me my my
the thinking was not you have to know
who I am when I walk into the room I am
NOT coming to speak at this mosque for
my personal identity purposes I'm coming
to speak at the mosque to to advance
what I view as public enrichment I am
also willing to do that around my smiley
identity if it turns out that
articulating forthcoming Lee that I am
in is smiley Muslim is not going to be
useful to a particular public interfaith
initiative I won't hide it I just want
to emphasize it right we choose to
emphasize things in our relationships
with people and if interfaith
cooperation is articulated as a civic a
public a political endeavor then
building bridges in the public square is
them is paramount which is to say we are
willing to subsume other identities
whether it's personal identities whether
its political opinions etc for the
purpose of achieving the paramount goal
which is those relationships
those Civic relationships